komplett geistig gestört 20 prozent
profit gemacht jetzt geht's bergab jungs
das was wir hier machen ist eine geld
verbrennungsmaschine ich weiß ja wie
krass der hype grabe um crypto
currencies ist und ich weiß dass viele
sich dafür interessieren und vielleicht
der ein oder andere kein geld hat oder
keine lust hat sein eigenes geld dafür
zu benutzen um selber da rein zu
investieren also habe ich mich dazu
entschlossen ein projekt zu starten bei
dem ich tausend euro in den raum werfen
und wir gemeinsam entscheiden für 30
tage was wir kaufen was wir verkaufen
was wir wie lange halten und meint rich
chat handelt mit 1000 euro 50
wir starten jetzt gleich damit dass die
möglichkeit bekommt über einen link
abzustimmen was wir als erstes kaufen
sollen und dann habt ihr eine stimme und
könnt euch für einen dieser crypto
währungen hier entscheiden welche wer
als erstes kaufen ihr habt im schwarm
komplette kontrolle darüber was wir
kaufen mit wie viel geld wenn ihr jetzt
gleich sagt wir wollen heute paulin
bitcoin mit 1000 euro und wir machen 30
tage lang gar nichts dann ist das auch
möglich das könnt ihr komplett frei
entscheiden
wo das wird also das erste ass et sein
dass wir kaufen jetzt habt ihr gleich
die entscheidung wie viel geld der 1000
euro wir darin investieren werden chad
was meint ihr werden fünf
antwortmöglichkeiten abstimmung was soll
mit 1 69 17 foto berny können wir auch
machen jetzt sind die preise gerade auch
gerade okay was machen das projekt genau
heute startet ist einfach ein guter
einstieg dann kann ich nicht sagen habt
ihr meine community gesehen wir haben es
trotzdem geschafft und vielen dank an
den sponsor des heutigen videos
cyberghost vpn cyberghost ist ein vpn
der neben dem verstecken ihre ip-adresse
und der verschlüsselung euro connection
noch einige weitere tolle dinge kann
beispielsweise ist es mit cyberghost
kein problem euch zugang zu den ganzen
tollen content zu liefern denen es
weltweit so gibt so könnt ihr dank des
vpn es problemlos auf alle shows
sendungen und filme von über 35
streaming anbietern wie netflix und
diesel plus zugreifen die es eigentlich
nur in bestimmten ländern oder regionen
gibt wenn es ihre lieblingssendung also
nur in amerika gibt schaaf cyberghost
hier abhilfe denn das aufheben der
länder restrictions ist quasi die
spezialität von cyberghost genauso das
ganze wird schon von über 38 millionen
nutzern weltweit genutzt ohne dass
irgendwelche privaten daten gespeichert
werden was auch immer ihr also macht
eure daten bleiben eure daten und sind
komplett safe niemand kann darauf
zugreifen selbst cyberghost nicht ich
könnte jetzt noch erzählen das ist ein
immer wachsendes netz aus über 6.500
servern in 90 ländern gibt cyberghost
auf allen gängigen plattformen ios
windows oder mac verfügbar ist und dass
ein abonnement an sieben geräten
gleichzeitig genutzt werden kann aber
wichtig ist vor allem dass er ich selber
dank der 45 tage geld-zurück-garantie
davon überzeugen könnt über den ersten
link in der video beschreibung und nur
über den ersten link in der video
beschreibung bekommt ihr 84 prozent auf
das drei jahre euro und noch vier monate
geschenkt also checkt das auf jeden fall
aus und kümmert euch um eure sicherheit
im internet ich bin ehrlich super
dankbar dass ich jetzt schon zum zweiten
mal mit cyberghost zusammenarbeiten kann
nur so ist es möglich dass ich für so
ein video jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr
geld in die hand nehmen oder so projekte
wie bist du hier umsetzen kann und euch
den content kostenlos zur verfügung
stellen kann es ist also wirklich eine
win-win-situation und jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video abstimmung ist leicht ihr
könnt entscheiden zwischen 69 187
fortführen ii und 1000 euro okay es ist
relativ eindeutig bis dato mit 68 40 mit
69%
rennbooten ja wieso lassen
69 prozent hat ford rallye gewonnen wir
werden am ersten tag des projektes 420
euro
420 euro heute warum investieren gerne
noch mal ganz kurz eine abstimmung ob
die lieferung hebeln oder ob wir das
einfach so kaufen ganz kurz erklärung
hebeln bedeutet wir können mit geld
handeln das wir nicht haben wir können
quasi alle drei darauf anwenden dadurch
würden wir drei mal so viel gewinn
machen aber auch gleichzeitig dreimal so
viel verlust ihr könnt es entscheidend
dass ich überhaupt bereit war leute
hebeln zu lassen und nicht einfach nur
zu investieren war die dümmste
entscheidung an diesem gesamten projekt
die entscheidung des safe meine
prediction das geld ist in zwei stunden
weg das kann vielleicht sein was für
hebel größen sollten wir in die
abstimmungen mit reinnehmen machen wir
zwei drei fünf acht und zehn das problem
an der ganzen sache ich hatte das selber
noch nie gemacht also ich hab nie
leverage foto gefällt ich hatte
überhaupt keine ahnung 0
ist vertrauenswürdig oder wenn ich ein
projekt mache bei dem die community
darüber entscheidet wie wir crypto
investieren und ich selber so wenig
ahnung habe dass wir uns noch ein video
dazu angucken müssen perfekt fritsch
habt ihr euch für entschieden da wollen
wir jetzt rein wollen wir long gehen
oder gehen wir schon okay mit knapp 80
prozent für long entschieden tp
slg use only trifft etf
ist das denn hierfür scheiße
ist irgendjemand der ahnung hat freunde
unser erster trade kaufen long
liquidation preis sind 1637
1607 30 jahre kuba ist so weit entfernt
man sieht dass hier noch nicht mal
seht ihr das zack schon zwei prozent im
profit so leicht ist es geld zu
verdienen back to normal wenn irgend
jemand zuguckt der das gerade nicht
versteht als sehr sehr schlechten witz
als das was es ist dann möchte ich das
hier noch mal ganz deutlich sagen mach
das bitte nicht so wie ich das war
geradewegs das absolute negativ beispiel
wie man das nicht machen sollte aber du
führst deine community an trading an und
ich sehe ja schon was kommen wird es tut
mir leid ich habe wirklich kein bock auf
komplett glattgebügelten content ich
wüsste wie ich diesen ganzen kommentaren
entkommen würde wenn ich sowas nämlich
einfach nicht machen würde aber ich habe
halt bock drauf und ich glaube es ist
witzig das zu machen was ich das privat
nicht mache das ist keiner von euch
privat machen sollte ist hoffentlich
klar und wenn nicht dann möchte ich das
gerne hiermit noch einmal klarmachen wie
sie keinen humor geht gibt das wäre
wirklich sehr wild dann würde ich sofort
rein rennen investieren
das gibt's ja
[Applaus]
ich hatte die der community keine
entscheidungsgewalt geben sollen ja das
ist wirklich schrecklich dass hier so
viele leute deutsch wellen aber juni mit
zweiter trade ist fest ihr habt euch
führt coin entschieden dann lasst uns
jetzt mal abstimmen mit wie viel geld
wie in deutsch investieren wollen kostet
uns ja nichts ja außer eure ehre dir
zusammengeknüllt und einfach so wegwirft
ok sehr gut das freut mich aber dort mit
nur einem euro
absoluter traum ok so wie es gerade
scheint wird dort voraussichtlich mit
einem euro geshortet ich glaube aber
genau mit dieser taktik kommen wir sehr
schnell um sehr viel geld genauso mit
wie viel leverage sollen wir dort
shorten okay ist relativ klar wir
shorten deutschen mit einem leverage von
was soll die scheiße wir müssen 50er
hebel nehmen euro nominalwert das nicht
weniger als fünf usdp sein okay wir
müssen das mit fünf euro machen dann
nehmen wir 20 oder abgegeben
wir sind vier prozent im plus 7 im plus
bei mainz and gemacht zehn prozent 11
prozent
falsche richtung falsche richtung 20
prozent im minus 15 20 20 23 prozent
das war's ich habe damit nichts zu tun
es war euer trade seht ihr was ihr für
geld verbrannt haben
okay wir traden carano zack hier habt
ihr den start in ihr braucht euch seht
ihr dass
dahinter das ding kennt nur eine
richtung mit was für einem leverage
wollen mitreden okay sagt wir hebeln mit
einem 20er hebel und jetzt müssen wir
nur noch entscheiden mit welchem betrag
abstimmung ist durch derzeit komplett
geistig gestört begehen long oder
mittzwanziger hebel und 187 euro und es
würde sagen wir kaufen einfach
22 prozent im plus jetzt ist die frage
machen wir daraus einen vernünftigen
date rape und nehmen dann einfach
unserem profi traust oder seite komplett
denkt und lassen wollte es einfach
drinnen lassen abstimmung is life daraus
ja wir sind bei 20 wir gehen für
marktpreis raus und haben 20 prozent
profit gemacht so nämlich schnell profit
mitnehmen zack zack 20 ganz schnelle
welle meine position war nur zehn dollar
deine position war wirklich nur zehn
dollar das ist so eine gottlose wieder
rein sagt ihr
das ist einfach risiko bruder das ist so
oder so risiko ich lasse hier leute von
die ich noch nie in meinem leben gesehen
habe mit geld traden ohne dass sie in
irgendeiner weise erfahrung haben da
unsere order wurde gefüllt 25 dollar
direkt im plus einfach easy money 37
dollar 40 dollar 47 dollar 50 dollar no
problem
warren buffett hat angerufene möchte
dich einstellen zehn euro - 13 euro im
minus 14 euro man jetzt geht's bergab
jetzt geht's bergab jungs der erdkern
ich war hier gar nichts
und 70 hebelspuren
ja stimmt auch das wäre sehr sehr gut
wir sind so knapp am liquidation preis
vorbei und jetzt geht aber wieder wie
auf einer rakete ganz nach oben eher
trade bitte nicht nachmachen des rheines
zocken hat nichts mit trading zu tun new
york kann ich eine million prozent
unterschreiben das was wir hier machen
ist eine geld verbrennungsmaschine
tag nummer drei fast eine woche her
seitdem wir das community crypto event
gestartet haben ich habe nicht ein
einziges mal reingeguckt die position
auf gelöst habt ihr alles verloren oh
mein gott chat 0 positionen jacky das
ist gab margin call sich auf einer
anderen rolle
na gut ist doch alles gut eure position
ist noch da ihr seid 640 euro im plus
cat
oil riecher das hier ist ganz ganz krank
wir haben noch 482 dollar und investiert
ihr könnt jetzt entscheiden ob ihr diese
position halten wollte oder sie auflösen
wollen also abstimmung ist live aber
überlegt es euch gut mit 58 prozent hat
sich der chat für das vergrößern der
position entschieden wie viel von den
482 euro die wir noch zur verfügung
haben sollen wir wieder reinstecken mit
48 prozent also fast der absoluten
mehrheit entscheidet sich der chat dafür
weitere 100 euro in gt rium mit 5v hebel
zu investieren oder wurde gefüllt
wir haben jetzt noch 380 dollar in der
rolle mit 51 prozent entscheidet sich
der chat für bitcoin long fünfer hebel
mit 69 euro sagt das war die nächste
position freue mich sehr und glaube das
wird noch richtig heiß und wir machen
die tage weiter
[Musik]
wie viel geld sind unsere position im
plus im minus was auch immer ok ok 25
dollar im minus mit unserem bitcoin
trade terium dafür stabil wie eh und je
60 prozent im plus ganz ganz krank
sondern die position jetzt so halten die
wir jetzt gerade haben halten halten
halten gewinn mitnehmen ja erhalten
halten holt wir befinden uns hier und
wir haben hier gekauft das kann noch
richtig richtig saftig werden was machen
wir mit der bitcoin position chat
scheint sich auch ziemlich einig zu sein
bitcoin werden wir nach kaufen wir haben
2 189 us-dollar noch in unserem account
hat sich mit der absoluten mehrheit für
69 euro
bitcoin nachkaufen entschieden die order
ist abgegeben markt oder ausgeführt und
jetzt sind wir mit 175 dollar drin
anstatt 90
es war klar dass es irgendwann passieren
würde 28,4 prozent und damit auf platz
eins ist das bedeutet als nächstes
werden wir mit unserem geld handeln so
sieht gerade aus hier ist anfang mai
supercross hoch und dann ging es hier so
bergab widget hat sich mit 59 prozent
dafür entschieden zu shorten jetzt ist
die frage wie viel geld sollen wir auf
diese idee setzen abstimmung geht auch
in eine sehr bestimmte richtung mit zwei
stimmen mehr hat 17 gewonnen das
bedeutet wir werden mit dem gesamten
geld was wir haben werden wir dort
handeln
[Musik]
absolute mehrheit entscheidet sich für
geschaute dort mittzwanziger hebel es
kann ja auch sein dass es funktioniert
einfach
nur schrecklich ich weiß gar nicht was
ich dazu sagen soll also ihr könnt
einmal entscheiden ob wir take profit
und stop loss einrichten wollen wie
gesagt das kann uns dabei helfen wenn
wir nicht aktiv dabei sind unsere
position zu verkaufen in egal welche
richtung ok sieht relativ eindeutig aus
chat hat sich für
0,28 und 300 dollar gewinn entschieden
dass eindeutig also wir bestätigen take
profit bei 0,28 das bedeutet wenn der
goldpreis auf 0,28 fällt also hier unten
auf diese linie dann löst unsere
position aus und wir haben 300 euro
gewinn gemacht und ansonsten machen wir
das nächste mal bei uns auf und alles
ist weg oder ob take profit und stop
loss wichtig für uns und dieses projekt
gewesen werden das werden wir jetzt mal
gemeinsam schauen denn ich habe keine
ahnung was in den letzten zwei monaten
wo ich nicht rein geschaut habe aus
diesem projekt geworden ist dass er
jetzt die ganzen crypto dinger sind alle
wieder komplett in die höhe geschossen
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wir
vorher einmal so ein stück zu weit
gedeckt sind und dass einfach nichts
mehr da ist
ist gut
wir haben es geschafft innerhalb von
sechs oder sieben trades aus
1200 us-dollar 9 dollar und 26 dollar
cent zu machen ja soll ich dazu sagen
okay also ein learning nämlich mit
vielleicht sollte ich die
entscheidungsgewalt für meine
investments nicht an meinen twitch
scheck übergeben das könnte möglichkeit
eins sein möglichkeit zwei könnte seien
nicht mit geld handeln dass man nicht
besitzt vielleicht auch nicht ganz
falsch und learning 3 ist ich sollte
wieder anfangen regelmäßig zu streamen
und ihr sollte den kanal abonnieren und
das video like mainz euch gefallen hat
und noch mal vielen dank an cyberghost
vpn die dieses video möglich gemacht
haben checkt den ersten link in einer
video beschreibung aus könnt euch
cyberghost vpn vielen vielen dank
couscous bis nächste woche macht es gut
[Musik]